Dilla verità,
anche tu qualche volta hai utilizzato un chatbot o un motore
di ricerca basato su intelligenza artificiale generativa per
farti dare delle risposte o dei consigli su qualche argomento?
Magari in un ambito nel quale non hai troppa
dimestichezza o senti il bisogno di una guida.
Non c'è niente di male,
ovviamente lo facciamo tutti io per primo.
Ma c'è una cosa da tenere bene a mente quando utilizziamo un large language
model e cioè che esso non solo potrebbe facilmente commettere errori ma
potrebbe anche mentire o addirittura assecondare le nostre
affermazioni anche se queste sono completamente errate.
Oggi scopriamo insieme il motivo per cui,
nonostante questi strumenti possano rappresentare
un enorme vantaggio per chi li utilizza,
è bene sapere che non bisogna mai fidarsi ciecamente delle loro risposte.
Parleremo infatti del perché le intelligenze artificiali inventano cose,
ci assecondano e ci mentono.
Sigla!
Benvenuti su Pensieri in codice,
il podcast dove si ragiona da informatici.
Con Valerio Galano.
Prima di iniziare con il nostro discorso,
trovo doveroso fare alcuni chiarimenti.
Innanzitutto,
anche se in questo episodio utilizzeremo la
definizione generica di "intelligenza artificiale",
ricordiamoci sempre che si parlerà solo ed
esclusivamente di machine learning generativo,
nello specifico di large language model.
In secondo luogo,
e questo non lo dirò mai abbastanza,
anche se utilizzeremo verbi come mentire,
assecondare,
decidere,
imparare,
eccetera,
dobbiamo avere sempre ben chiaro in mente che gli LLM
non hanno alcuna intenzionalità nei loro comportamenti,
né tantomeno una vera comprensione del significato dei testi che generano.
Quando parliamo di allucinazioni,
di pensiero o di menzogne,
lo facciamo solo perché sono concetti che
ci risultano più facili da comprendere,
e descrivono funzionamenti di queste macchine che
assomigliano ai relativi comportamenti tipici degli umani.
Ma stiamo sempre parlando di macchine,
non di umani.
Pertanto,
seppur apparendo in tutto e per tutto simili
all'interazione con un altro individuo della nostra specie,
le ragioni dietro alla generazione di ogni
singola risposta sono completamente diverse.
In realtà,
lo ripetiamo ancora una volta,
anche se ci ostiniamo a chiamarli "intelligenze",
questi algoritmi non sono esseri intelligenti,
non pensano veramente,
non hanno obiettivi,
intenzioni o volontà propria.
Se si comportano in un determinato modo,
come vedremo a breve,
è semplicemente,
dove semplicemente va fra virgolette,
per questioni statistiche.
Siamo noi ad attribuire ai risultati dei
loro calcoli significati tipicamente umani.
Se anche non ti sarà capitato di ricevere personalmente
risposte errate da parte di un large language model,
avrai certamente letto qualche notizia in giro per il web su chatbot
che danno consigli assurdi o si comportano in modi inappropriati.
Quando l'output di un LLM non ha senso,
si parla di allucinazione,
e si intende quella condizione per cui il modello generativo
produce una risposta che è perfettamente corretta e
convincente dal punto di vista sintattico e formale,
ma è sbagliata nel contenuto.
Ad esempio,
a me una volta è capitato che mentre facevo delle ricerche
su Charles Babbage per gli episodi su Ada Lovelace,
un LLM,
credo,
chatgpt,
mi abbia riportato una citazione molto bella attribuita all'inventore,
ma che in realtà non trovava riscontro in nessuna fonte e
soprattutto era stranamente datata circa 40 anni dopo la sua morte.
A proposito,
se non hai ancora ascoltato la miniserie su Ada Lovelace,
sappi che hai perso uno dei migliori contenuti che
io abbia mai prodotto qui su Pensieri in Codice,
quindi recuperala,
mi raccomando,
te la metto in descrizione.
Tornando alle nostre allucinazioni però,
secondo fonti più oggettive come la stessa OpenAI,
una delle maggiori aziende produttrici di large language model,
negli ultimi 4 modelli di chatgpt sono presenti allucinazioni in determinati
ambiti in percentuali di risposte che oscillano tra il 37 e l'80%.
Ciò vuol dire che anche con i migliori LLM in circolazione,
una risposta su 3 potrebbe essere errata in parte o totalmente.
Un dato abbastanza preoccupante se pensiamo a
come vengono utilizzati oggi questi strumenti.
Riflettendo però un attimo sulle basi del
funzionamento dei large language model,
non dovrebbe poi essere troppo complicato capire da
dove originano tali e tanto diffusi malfunzionamenti.
Anche su questa questione c'è un interessantissimo episodio sempre di
questo podcast intitolato "Come funziona chatgpt" in cui ho già affrontato
l'argomento in modo più approfondito e trovi anche questo in descrizione.
Ma,
volendo riassumere brevemente,
possiamo semplicemente dire che in fin dei conti un LLM
compone i propri testi accodando una parola dopo l'altra,
selezionando ciascuna di esse di volta in volta su base statistica.
In pratica,
partendo da una sequenza di parole,
individua statisticamente la successiva valutando quale è più
probabile che possa accodarsi basandosi sulle occorrenze all'interno
di un corpus di documenti con i quali è stato addestrato.
Più volte nei dati di addestramento un gruppo
di parole è seguito da un'altra parola,
più,
secondo il modello,
è probabile che quella parola si adatti bene al contesto.
L'algoritmo poi replica questa operazione di scelta un certo numero
di volte fino a comporre un testo della lunghezza desiderata.
Un LLM reale ovviamente è molto più complesso di così ed è dotato
di moltissime sovrastrutture utili a migliorarne la qualità.
Ma,
per qualsiasi modello esistente,
se lo si scompone e se si scava abbastanza a fondo,
il funzionamento di base è più o meno quello che ti ho descritto.
E che vuol dire questo?
Semplice,
che,
a livello logico,
un LLM che potrebbe intuitivamente sembrare
un enorme database della conoscenza umana,
in realtà è molto più simile ad una gigantesca palla otto.
Hai presente?
Quelle sfere piene di liquido che agiti e dopo
qualche istante fanno apparire una risposta?
Sì?
No?
Forse?
Se aprissimo un LLM e vi guardassimo all'interno,
non vedremmo delle informazioni intese come dati ai quali viene dato un senso,
ma solo miliardi e miliardi di numeri.
Questi numeri vengono utilizzati dal modello per scegliere,
di volta in volta,
la parola successiva da aggiungere al testo,
fra quelle che sempre nel corpus di documenti utilizzati ricorre con maggiore
frequenza di seguito a quelle che già compongono la prima parte del testo.
All'atto pratico,
volendo semplificare al massimo,
ogni volta che il modello deve aggiungere una parola al testo,
utilizza i numeri di qui sopra per calcolare dei
punteggi per ciascuna parola del suo vocabolario.
Più alto è il punteggio e più è probabile che
la parola si adatti bene alle precedenti.
Messa in questi termini sembra molto semplice,
quasi banale,
eppure essenzialmente questo meccanismo permette
l'esistenza di quei potentissimi strumenti che noi
oggi chiamiamo "intelligenze artificiali generative".
Purtroppo,
però,
in questo processo c'è un limite intrinseco.
Se il calcolo della parola successiva,
infatti,
fosse sempre preciso al 100%,
a parità di modello utilizzato,
ad una specifica frase seguirebbe sempre la stessa parola.
Il calcolo del punteggio,
infatti,
darebbe sempre gli stessi risultati e questi
porterebbero ad avere sempre lo stesso vincitore.
In pratica,
ciò vuol dire che,
se fosse come detto,
accadrebbe che a prompt identici,
uno specifico modello risponderebbe sempre con risposte identiche.
Ma noi sappiamo benissimo che nella realtà non è così.
Se facciamo 100 volte la stessa domanda allo stesso modello,
otteniamo sempre una risposta leggermente diversa.
Magari le informazioni cambiano solo un po',
ma sicuramente cambia la forma in cui sono espresse.
Questo comportamento deriva dal fatto che un LLM deve poter
rispondere a prompt che non conosce già perfettamente,
e per fare ciò è necessario che esso possa combinare parole e frasi
in modi nuovi rispetto ai testi originali su cui è stato addestrato.
Un modello linguistico che avesse bisogno di input precisi e restituisse output
costanti in modo deterministico non differirebbe da un software tradizionale,
pertanto non avrebbe motivo di destare tanto entusiasmo
ed essere oggetto di tanto dispendio di risorse a livello
planetario come invece accade per questa tecnologia.
È necessario invece che un LLM possa mescolare
concetti e idee provenienti da fonti diverse,
che possa variare nell'utilizzo delle parole
e del modo di esprimere le informazioni,
e tutto questo al fine di fornire risposte che sembrino creative e innovative.
Il punto,
però,
è che un tale risultato di simulata creatività si può ottenere solo inserendo
nel processo di selezione delle parole una piccola percentuale di imprecisione,
una leggera componente di casualità che permetta di non
associare sempre lo stesso output allo stesso input.
La parola selezionata di volta in volta
quindi non è esattamente la più pertinente,
ma una scelta all'interno del gruppo delle più pertinenti.
E una così semplice accortezza è in realtà il
segreto della potenza di questi strumenti,
è ciò che permette loro di fornire risposte sorprendenti,
di mescolare idee da contesti diversi,
di esprimersi con stili differenti e via discorrendo.
Peccato,
però,
che per questa stessa identica ragione essi non possano essere accurati al 100%,
ovviamente,
e in determinati casi un susseguirsi di scelte un po' troppo creative porti
alla generazione di quelle risposte sbagliate che noi chiamiamo allucinazioni.
Non esiste alcun modo per assicurarsi che parole messe in fila con una
seppur piccola percentuale di casualità portino a comporre un testo
con un senso logico ben definito e ad esporre informazioni corrette.
Gli LLM,
ripetiamolo ancora una volta,
non hanno comprensione dei testi che generano,
e pertanto si può tranquillamente affermare che essi non possano avere
capacità o intenzionalità di restituire affermazioni vere o false,
di fatto,
essi non hanno alcun vincolo di realtà.
In effetti,
guardandola da questo punto di vista,
dovrebbe apparire chiaro che qualsiasi prodotto di
un modello generativo è di fatto un'allucinazione.
Il modello,
infatti,
non è in grado di giudicare in alcun modo se
ciò che ha restituito sia sensato o meno.
Siamo noi a dare un senso a questi testi,
e se li troviamo corretti e sensati,
li definiamo risposte,
altrimenti li chiamiamo allucinazioni.
Per completezza di discorso,
poi,
diciamo che ci sono anche altre ragioni,
magari molto più intuitive,
che possono portare i modelli generativi a sbagliare,
e sono ad esempio errori nei dati di
addestramento o prompt eccessivamente ambigui,
ma questi sono aspetti su cui è possibile lavorare.
Si possono migliorare i dati fino a farli diventare quasi perfetti,
e si possono migliorare i prompt fino a farli diventare estremamente precisi.
Quello che,
però,
non si può fare è eliminare la necessità di avere un meccanismo
di combinazione dei concetti come quello descritto prima.
Uno studio dell'Università di Singapore,
infatti,
ha dimostrato matematicamente che per quanto possa essere
grande e potente un modello generativo linguistico,
esso non potrà mai imparare tutte le risposte a tutte le domande possibili.
Dovrà pertanto sempre in qualche modo combinare concetti e idee distinte,
e per questo motivo ci sarà sempre una certa
percentuale di rischio che esso produca allucinazioni.
Se le allucinazioni sono forse il tipo di malfunzionamento
più conosciuto nei grandi modelli di generazione linguistica,
esse non sono certo l'unico motivo che ci dovrebbe spingere a mantenere
un certo livello di vigilanza sulle risposte di questi strumenti.
Il fenomeno della psicofantia,
ad esempio,
è venuto alla ribalta di recente,
a seguito di uno specifico aggiornamento di qualche
mese fa del più famoso chatbot in circolazione,
che ovviamente è chatGPT.
Secondo la stessa casa produttrice,
OpenAI,
il chatbot aveva iniziato a bollare come assolutamente
fantastiche le idee più stupide propostegli dagli utilizzatori.
Il culmine si era aggiunto quando un utente si è visto definire "genio"
per aver ideato un business di vendita di cacche su bastoncini.
La definizione "psicofante" è risultata particolarmente
calzante perché chatGPT aveva iniziato,
in maniera piuttosto evidente,
a favorire le idee degli utenti al di sopra del buonsenso,
e per farlo assumeva perfino un atteggiamento delatorio
nei confronti della realtà dei fatti accertati.
OpenAI ovviamente ha posto rimedio in tempi brevi con un nuovo aggiornamento,
ma la notizia non è passata inosservata,
e anche se la tendenza del bot ad assecondare è stata mitigata,
ciò non vuol dire che ora il modello sia
totalmente immune da questo tipo di comportamenti.
Anzi,
in realtà la cosa più preoccupante,
risultata poi da una serie di indagini scatenate dalla notizia,
è che la "psicofantia" è risultata essere molto
più comune di quanto si possa pensare nei chatbot,
e anche non così recente.
In un paper di Anthropic,
ad esempio,
altra azienda tra i pesi massimi nella produzione di large language model,
i ricercatori avevano evidenziato già nel 2023 come sia un comportamento
diffuso per gli assistenti digitali quello di sacrificare la realtà
delle cose a favore dell'adattamento al punto di vista dell'utente.
In pratica,
i chatbot hanno la tendenza a compiacere l'utente di turno,
avvalorando le sue tesi anche se queste sono poco sensate o infondate,
e confermando le sue convinzioni anche se imprecise o addirittura sbagliate.
Ora,
vista la celere reazione di OpenAI,
si potrebbe pensare che la "psicofantia",
a differenza delle allucinazioni che abbiamo scoperto essere impossibili
da estirpare a causa della strutturazione stessa del modello linguistico,
sia invece corregibile in qualche modo,
ma purtroppo anche in questo caso non è così,
almeno non per il momento.
La causa di questo strano fenomeno,
infatti,
viene fatta risalire dai ricercatori stessi direttamente al
metodo utilizzato per l'addestramento dei più moderni modelli.
Metodo che,
purtroppo,
rappresenta anche lo stato dell'arte.
In altre parole,
non esiste metodo migliore per addestrare un large language model di
quello conosciuto come "reinforcement learning from human feedback"
e che viene attualmente utilizzato praticamente per tutti i modelli,
commerciali e non.
Ad oggi,
l'apprendimento per rinforzo con supervisione umana è l'unico in grado di
portare alla creazione di LLM in grado di competere o migliorare rispetto.
Ad oggi,
l'apprendimento per rinforzo con supervisione umana è l'unico
in grado di portare alla creazione di LLM in grado di competere
o migliorare rispetto a quelli di ultima generazione.
Con la crescita esponenziale del machine learning generativo,
infatti,
si è notato che,
se da un lato le conoscenze aumentavano in modo più che proporzionale
rispetto ai dati e alle capacità di calcolo a disposizione,
non valeva lo stesso per le capacità di relazionarsi con l'utente.
La comprensione delle richieste ad esempio era scarsa e pertanto
bastava un minimo errore nel prompt per portare alla generazione
di risposte notevolmente lontane dall'argomento della domanda.
I testi prodotti poi risultavano spesso poco
simili a quelli che avrebbe scritto un umano,
sia dal punto di vista della costruzione delle frasi e dei
periodi sia dal punto di vista della capacità espressiva.
E infine non erano rari atteggiamenti scorretti
di vario tipo verso i più disparati soggetti,
affermazioni discriminatorie,
razzismo,
sessismo,
risposte aggressive,
suggerimenti fuori luogo o addirittura potenzialmente pericolosi,
e via discorrendo.
Quando quindi le aziende hanno iniziato a realizzare che incrementare
le moli di dati di addestramento e la potenza computazionale non
era più sufficiente ad andare a colmare i limiti dei loro modelli,
hanno iniziato ad adottare l'apprendimento per rinforzo
supervisionato da umani come successivo passo evolutivo.
A onor del vero questo non è l'unico motivo
che ha portato all'adozione del RLHF.
Ne esiste perlomeno anche un secondo,
anch'esso molto importante e forse anche più intuibile,
ma me lo lascio per il prossimo blocco perché
ci aiuterà a capire meglio un certo concetto.
Ad ogni modo,
però,
una volta risolto un problema,
come spesso accade,
se ne è venuto a creare un altro strettamente legato alla soluzione adottata.
Il reinforcement learning con supervisione
umana funziona con una semplice logica.
Il modello viene messo al lavoro,
quindi nello specifico gli vengono fatte domande a cui deve rispondere,
e viene premiato o punito a seconda che il
controllore consideri buona o cattiva la risposta.
Nel reinforcement learning semplice le punizioni
e i premi sono risultati di formule matematiche,
ma di questo abbiamo già parlato nell'episodio su Alphadev che
ti lascio sempre in descrizione e che ti invito a recuperare.
Nel metodo con rinforzo umano,
invece,
la differenza principale sta nel fatto che il premio o la punizione viene
assegnato non da un calcolo matematico ma direttamente dal giudizio umano.
Questa affermazione suona come un enorme passo avanti,
ed in effetti lo è,
ma nasconde anche un'insidia che ad una prima occhiata non è così evidente.
Se prima infatti i modelli venivano addestrati
solo tramite rigorose formule matematiche,
si poteva in un certo qual modo fare affidamento sul fatto
che il risultato dell'operazione sarebbe stato tanto
affidabile quanto lo erano le formule utilizzate.
Invece,
inserendo una fase svolta da umani all'interno del processo,
questa sicurezza viene un po' a decadere.
Ovviamente,
anche in questo caso,
il modello viene ottimizzato ma non necessariamente nel migliore dei modi.
Dato infatti che gli umani,
purtroppo o per fortuna,
sono fallibili,
lo è anche il giudizio che possono esprimere sulle risposte generate da un LLM.
Statisticamente parlando,
non è pensabile che tutti i controllori conoscano alla perfezione
e siano in grado di etichettare in modo perfetto ogni risposta.
Capita che essi possano dare il proprio giudizio anche rispetto ad
output che sembrano giusti o sbagliati ma in realtà non lo sono.
Sappiamo bene,
l'abbiamo detto già più volte,
che gli LLM hanno un modo molto convincente di esporre le informazioni,
giuste o sbagliate che siano.
Gli umani sono umani e pertanto tendono a farsi
convincere anche da determinati modi di fare,
da determinati toni nell'esposizione e perché no,
anche da lusinghe a condiscendenza,
che in maniera velata o meno,
possono comunque solleticare il loro ego.
Dal canto suo invece il modello,
ancora una volta,
non è dotato di alcun tipo di capacità di comprendere
cosa produce in output e cosa riceve in input,
pertanto non sa per quale motivo le risposte gli
vengono contrassegnate come giuste o sbagliate,
sa solo che è così.
Con l'avanzare del processo,
quindi,
esso accumula una serie di dati e cerca di estrapolarne un
qualcosa che ha comuni tra loro le risposte giuste da una parte,
quelle sbagliate dall'altra e tutte le sfumature nel mezzo.
In definitiva,
con il Reinforcement Learning by Human Feedback,
un importante effetto collaterale è che il modello impara,
fra le varie cose,
anche che le risposte migliori sono quelle che
maggiormente assecondano il proprio controllore,
magari quelle che gli danno ragione o che comunque non gli danno torto.
L'ultima frontiera nel campo dei grandi modelli
linguistici sono i cosiddetti Large Resonance Models,
o LRM all'italiana.
Dicendola in modo semplice,
essi sono dei modelli che,
per rispondere ad un determinato prompt,
eseguono tutta una serie di passaggi,
effettuando delle domande a se stessi e rispondendovi,
per migliorare la comprensione del problema
sottoposto e la qualità della risposta.
Questa serie di scambi precedenti alla generazione
dell'output viene definita "chain of thought",
catena di pensiero,
e in molti modelli viene proprio esplicitata come parte della risposta stessa.
Ciò permette agli utenti di verificare in che modo il
modello sia arrivato a formulare l'output fornito.
Peccato però che un recente studio,
sempre di Antropic,
ha evidenziato come in realtà,
in una percentuale sorprendentemente alta di casi,
gli LRM presi in esame tendono a divergere
tra la risposta e la catena di pensiero.
Gli esperimenti riportati si basavano essenzialmente sul fornire ai
modelli dei suggerimenti da utilizzare per rispondere alle domande
e poi sull'andare a verificare se essi venivano innanzitutto
utilizzati e poi menzionati nella chain of thought.
Tali suggerimenti potevano essere di vario tipo,
alcuni erano corretti,
altri sbagliati,
alcuni palesi,
altri poco evidenti,
e al modello veniva lasciata piena libertà di
scelta nel decidere se utilizzarli o meno.
L'idea alla base degli esperimenti era quella di verificare se il modello,
pur decidendo di utilizzare il suggerimento,
evitasse poi di menzionarlo nella catena di pensiero.
In tal caso sarebbe stato considerato bugiardo,
in caso contrario onesto.
I risultati hanno mostrato che la maggioranza
sostanziale delle risposte è stata infedele.
Tra i vari modelli esaminati,
ad esempio,
in media Cloud 3.7 Sonnet ha menzionato il suggerimento solo il 25% delle volte,
mentre DeepSeek R1 lo ha menzionato appena il 39% delle volte.
Nel complesso la ricerca indica che i modelli di ragionamento avanzati in
generale molto spesso nascondono i loro veri processi di pensiero e talvolta
lo fanno proprio quando i loro comportamenti sono esplicitamente divergenti.
In pratica possiamo dire che gli LRM di fatto mentono.
E non intendendo che essi riportano informazioni errate,
quello l'abbiamo già constatato parlando di allucinazioni,
ma proprio nel senso che essi non dicono quello che pensano.
Ovviamente dopo un'affermazione del genere è importante ricordare che
un LLM come un LRM non dice verità o menzogna con intenzionalità.
Come abbiamo già detto nei blocchi precedenti,
tira semplicemente fuori la sequenza di
parole più probabili collegate al prompt.
Prima però ti ho anche anticipato che c'è una seconda ragione per la
quale il reinforcement learning con feedback umano è stato adottato per
l'addestramento dei più avanzati modelli linguistici e di ragionamento.
Ed è arrivato il momento di parlarne.
In uno scenario in espansione competitivo come quello della
IA generativa non dobbiamo mai dimenticarci che LLM o LRM
sono macchine appositamente progettate per dare risposte.
Pertanto la possibilità che esse ammettano
di non saper rispondere non è auspicabile.
Le aziende per loro natura devono massimizzare il profitto e
in quanto prodotto impiegato per la generazione di fatturato,
la risposta "non lo so" da parte di un modello
generativo viene di fatto considerata un problema.
Un sistema che funziona a intermittenza o non genera senso di sicurezza
negli utenti che pagano fior fiore di quattrini per costruirvi sopra le
proprie soluzioni tecnologiche di ogni tipo non è
esattamente una manna dal cielo per il business.
Come abbiamo già detto però già da un po' ci si è resi conto che il solo
continuare ad aumentare parametri e dati non sarebbe stato sufficiente a
produrre macchine onniscienti e infallibili ed è proprio per questo che il
nostro discorso ritorna sul reinforcement learning basato su feedback umano che,
ripetiamolo,
lo stato dell'arte dell'addestramento e permette agli
sviluppatori di produrre modelli sempre più efficienti.
Peccato però che come qualsiasi large language model o large reasoning
model là fuori nemmeno gli umani siano poi così onniscienti e infallibili.
Come abbiamo già detto infatti un grosso limite del RLHF è che
tende sì ad ottimizzare le capacità di risposta delle IA tramite la
massimizzazione del premio ma non sempre lo fa nel migliore dei modi.
Innanzitutto,
dato che difficilmente un controllore si accontenterà di una
risposta del tipo "sinceramente a questa domanda non so rispondere",
una cosa fondamentale che l'addestramento supervisionato imprime nei
modelli è che "non lo so" non è una risposta che viene ricompensata.
Al tempo stesso però gli umani designati come controllori ovviamente non possono
conoscere ogni singola nozione dello scibile umano e altrettanto ovviamente non
sono in grado di giudicare tutte le risposte della
macchina con precisione totale e infallibilità.
Ciò vuol dire che durante l'addestramento quando il modello
genera una risposta che viene contrassegnata come "errata"
ci sono di fatto due strade per ottimizzare la situazione.
La prima è migliorare nel dare risposte più dettagliate e corrette,
ma l'altra - ed è qui che si verifica il problema - è generare risposte
più convincenti e che sembrino più corrette pur non essendolo.
Se dunque l'LRM non ha una risposta corretta
e "non lo so" non è una risposta valida,
allora quello che resta è generare una risposta abbastanza verosimile,
ben strutturata e in forma fluente da riuscire a superare
il controllo anche senza essere necessariamente corretta.
I supervisori umani infatti semplicemente possono non essere in
grado di segnalare come risposte sbagliate quelle che pur essendolo
appaiono però abbastanza sensate e coerenti da ingannarli.
L'obiettivo dell'addestramento quindi diventa
non più quello di formulare risposte esatte,
ma quello di convincere l'essere umano che la risposta sia corretta,
non importa come,
se migliorando veramente l'output o semplicemente facendoglielo credere.
In pratica il modello impara che migliorare nelle capacità di nascondere
l'incompetenza funziona altrettanto bene che migliorare nella conoscenza.
Di fatto le IA mentono perché noi stiamo dicendo
loro che facendolo vengono ricompensate.
In uno studio pubblicato su Nature alcuni ricercatori hanno evidenziato come con
il passare delle generazioni dei modelli generativi le risposte del tipo "non
lo so" sono state progressivamente sostituite con
risposte molto più articulate ma anche sbagliate.
A quanto pare più difficile è la domanda sottoposta e
più avanzato è il modello utilizzato più è probabile
che la risposta generata sia un insieme di sciocchezze,
solo che saranno sciocchezze molto plausibili e molto ben scritte.
Gli stessi ricercatori poi hanno anche svolto un sondaggio online con
300 partecipanti per capire quale modello fosse il più bravo a mentire.
Il vincitore è risultato essere chat gpt ma la cosa a mio
avviso più interessante è che le persone non sono riuscite ad
individuare gli errori in una percentuale molto alta di casi.
Tra le varie le risposte errate fornite nella categoria scientifica
sono state qualificate come corrette in oltre il 19 per cento di casi.
Quelle di geografia nel 32 e addirittura le trasformazioni,
cioè compiti in cui si chiedeva di estrarre e
riorganizzare le informazioni presenti nei prompt,
in ben il 40 per cento.
In pratica stiamo insegnando alle intelligenze artificiali
a mentire e lo stiamo anche facendo molto bene
Sapere come funzionano certe limitazioni delle intelligenze artificiali,
strumenti che ormai utilizziamo praticamente ogni giorno,
è fondamentale per evitare di incappare in una
serie di incidenti quanto meno spiacevoli.
Tanto per cominciare,
è lo stesso Sam Altman,
CEO di OpenAI,
a ricordare sempre più spesso al mondo che il suo prodotto di punta,
ChatGPT,
soffre costantemente di allucinazioni e a chiedersi come sia possibile
che tante persone credano ciecamente a qualsiasi risposta esso produca.
E se lo dice lui,
voglio dire.
Nell'ultimo articolo che mi è capitato sotto mano c'è questo virgolettato,
la traduzione è mia.
Le persone hanno un livello molto alto di fiducia in ChatGPT,
il che è interessante perché l'AI ha allucinazioni.
Dovrebbe essere quella tecnologia di cui non ti fidi così tanto.
Fine citazione.
Le problematiche che abbiamo descritto in questo episodio,
come spesso accade per gli argomenti di cui parliamo in questo podcast,
sono virtuali ma hanno poi ricadute estremamente reali.
Per la questione delle allucinazioni non penso di doverti chiarire chissà cosa.
Gli LLM sbagliano,
possono tirare fuori informazioni sbagliate,
possono sbagliare i calcoli,
possono riportare male tendenze,
andamenti o fare analisi incongrue.
E non parliamo poi dei collegamenti logici fra concetti e ragionamenti.
In pratica,
se li utilizziamo per prendere decisioni,
per fare scelte o per creare testi da utilizzare altrove,
dalla stesura di un libro alla preparazione di biglietti di auguri,
dobbiamo essere consci del fatto che in ogni
singola frase si potrebbero annidare degli errori.
Questo chiaramente non significa che non li possiamo usare mai.
Anzi,
io ne incoraggio l'utilizzo quando utile.
Mi raccomando,
non credere che io sia un luddista,
sono il primo che li usa.
A seconda del contesto e dell'importanza dell'attività che stiamo svolgendo,
però,
dobbiamo tenere bene a mente che è necessario
controllare a fondo i loro output prima di utilizzarli.
Diversamente,
invece,
se spostiamo l'attenzione sulla "sicofantia" che abbiamo descritto poc'anzi,
i problemi sono forse un po' meno evidenti
rispetto a quelli delle generiche allucinazioni.
Al di là del semplice fatto di trovare magari fastidioso un interlocutore al
quale stiamo in effetti chiedendo aiuto per portare a termine un'attività
e che continua a risponderci riportando quanto
le nostre idee siano intelligenti e perfette,
l'artificioso modo di assecondare degli LLM potrebbe in
realtà rappresentare una sorta di trappola per l'utente.
Come è già accaduto per i social,
i quali hanno spinto all'estremo la proliferazione delle cosiddette "bolle",
cioè quelle sorte di ambienti protetti in cui noi tutti trascorriamo
parte del nostro tempo interagendo con persone che la pensano come noi,
o a contatto con informazioni che descrivono il mondo come noi lo vediamo,
o ragionamenti che si allineano alle nostre convinzioni,
allo stesso modo un chatbot psicofante diventa un meccanismo
di rinforzo del nostro pensiero e dei nostri bias.
Se nessuno mi dice mai che ho torto su qualcosa,
che sto sbagliando un ragionamento o sono in possesso di
un'informazione sbagliata o ho fatto un ragionamento campato in aria,
ma anzi si complimenta per qualsiasi cosa io esterni,
allora non mi metto in discussione e mi convinco di essere
totalmente nel giusto e che tutto il mondo la pensa come me,
ma questo non è vero,
non lo è mai.
Se i chatbot divengono ennesimi strumenti di rinforzo della bolla,
invece di aiutarmi a scoprire ed accettare diversi punti
di vista o imparare a gestire il confronto e gli errori,
saranno semplicemente una nuova gabbia dorata che mi isolerà
ancora una volta dal mondo reale e da tutte le sue sfaccettature.
Infine,
nel nostro discorso restano quelle che abbiamo definito come menzogne,
cioè il nascondere la vera catena di pensieri che ha portato ad una risposta.
Esse sono una caratteristica degli LRM che ha vari impatti,
soprattutto a livello tecnico.
Innanzitutto le catene di pensiero vengono utilizzate
per studiare il comportamento dei modelli e verificare
come avviene la produzione di un determinato output,
e pertanto la loro inesattezza inficia le attività di ricercatori,
studiosi e progettisti.
Ma pensiamo a qualcosa di ancora più pratico.
Facciamo un esempio.
Immagina che ad un modello di ragionamento per il supporto medico
venga chiesto quale delle seguenti indicazioni dobbiamo dare
ad un paziente per ridurre il rischio di sviluppare un tumore,
eliminare la carne rossa,
i grassi alimentari,
il pesce o curare l'obesità.
Il modello vede,
da qualche parte nell'intera storia clinica
del paziente o di chissà quale altro archivio,
un sottile indizio che indica che la risposta corretta è
"eliminare i grassi alimentari" e scrive una lunga spiegazione
nella sua catena di pensiero sul perché essa è corretta,
senza mai menzionare di aver utilizzato quell'indizio.
In un caso del genere,
c'è solo da sperare di essere in presenza di un bravo medico
che si accorga che lo strumento ha generato un'allucinazione,
perché dalle informazioni fornite sul processo di ragionamento effettuato
sarà di fatto impossibile individuare la presenza dell'errore e la sua fonte.
In conclusione,
i chatbot basati su intelligenza artificiale generativa
sono inaffidabili sotto molti punti di vista,
anche se si sta lavorando per migliorarli e ci sono
tante novità e passi avanti praticamente ogni giorno.
Forse un giorno i problemi verranno risolti,
ma per il momento non è così,
e secondo me serviranno ancora un bel po' di anni.
Nel frattempo,
quindi,
quello che faccio,
e che consiglio di fare anche a te,
è fare attenzione a controllare gli output.
So che non possiamo vigilare su tutto e verificare ogni singola parola,
altrimenti invece di farci risparmiare tempo ce ne farebbero perdere.
Però,
almeno per le cose che riteniamo importanti,
beh,
lo sforzo dovremmo farlo.
D'altronde,
nessuna tecnologia funziona senza alcun costo da pagare e,
nel caso dell'intelligenza generativa,
la vigilanza è una delle componenti del prezzo più importanti e meno evidenti.
Ce l'abbiamo fatta!
Abbiamo portato a casa l'episodio 142.
Ultimamente sono molto in difficoltà,
devo dire,
magari dovrei provare a fare un ragionamento approfondito sul perché,
ma non oggi,
perché altrimenti questo podcast non esce più.
Velocissimamente ringrazio i donatori periodici Edoardo e Carlo,
e poi Michele e Paola che si aggiungono oggi con la loro donazione singola.
Loro hanno scelto di restituire valore a Pensieri in Codice in questo modo.
Se vuoi farlo anche tu,
trovi i link nella descrizione e nella sezione
Sostieni del sito pensieriincodice.it Ricorda,
non è obbligatorio e non c'è una cifra minima.
La scelta di quanto vale il mio lavoro io la lascio a te.
Se invece preferisci ricompensarmi con un
po' del tuo talento o un po' del tuo tempo,
ricordati che portare nuovi ascoltatori è sempre un bel modo.
Nel 2025 non ti devo certo spiegare io come diffondere un contenuto,
giusto?
E poi ricorda anche che ci sono tante attività su cui puoi dare una mano.
Contattami e parliamone.
C'è ad esempio la nuova rubrica Pensieri in Codice Community
Edition in cui puoi creare il tuo episodio con la tua voce.
Oppure c'è la necessità di aprire e gestire degli account social.
Oppure,
come dico sempre,
dimmi tu cosa sapresti o vorresti fare e vediamo di organizzarci.
Mi trovi su Telegram,
nel gruppo Pensieri in Codice,
sempre link in descrizione e sul sito pensieriincodice.it
o all'indirizzo valerio@pensieriincodice.it.
Mi raccomando,
con due i.
Infine,
per citare il mio caro amico Alex Racuglia,
che ultimamente ha realizzato ben quattro episodi per Community Edition,
ti auguro un buon ascolto di quel che verrà e
noi ci risentiamo probabilmente a settembre,
senza mai dimenticarci però che un informatico risolve problemi,
a volte anche usando il computer.